a lot of you are spending 25 30 for your
cabernets from California this you
should be able to find in that 15 to 20
range a noon 2021 Reserva Cabernet
Sauvignon 91 points James sucklin 16 to
20 out there cabs are expensive
except there are parts of the world
where you can get the old school Chile
is one of them I have high hopes for
this one hopefully this brings us home
let's give it a snippy sniff
beautiful cherries a little hint of a
pepper let's give it a whirl
this is going to win really good
Elegance grapefruit integration
beautiful red flowers meets a little
hint of like tobacco or almost like dark
chocolate really nice long finish creamy
what I would call Oaky vanilla on the
long finish really nice I think James
succulent nailed this I think this is a
91 Point wine